สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensible  Thai ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ด้วยกันฟังค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ในวันนี้เนี่ยครู
ปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบกับทุกคนอีกแล้วค่ะ
ห้ามเบื่อเรา
นะวันนี้เราพบกันวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กวันจันทร์อ้าวันนี้เป็นวันจันทร์เนอะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะครูชิ
19 เดือนอะไรคะ
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะ
พุทธศักราช
2567 อ่าปีค.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะปีค.ศหรือ
คริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะค่ะนะวันนี้ก็เรามาพบกับทุกคนใน
วันจันทร์นะคะวันที่ 19 เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะเห็นมั้ยครูปุ๊กพูดเร็วๆนัก
เรียนก็เข้าใจค่ะ
นะเพะนักเรียนเพราะเรารู้ไงเพราะเรารู้
ว่าถ้านักเรียนฟังไม่ทันเดี๋ยวนักเรียนไป
เปลี่ยนสปีดเอาได้อ๋อก็จะเป็นแบบวันนี้
ครูปุ๊กกับูชิ
ออเปลี่ยนให้มันช้าลงใช่มยใช่ค่ะเรียนบอก
ทำไมครูชิใช้ภาษาอังกฤษคะอะไรนะคะเปลี่ยน
สปีดไงเห็นมอ๋อเปลี่ยนความเร็วใช่มยอ่าก็
คือจริงๆบางทีเนี่ยบางทีคนไทยก็พูดทับ
ศัพท์แต่เห็นมยคะว่าเสียงเี่มันเป็นเสียง
ภาษาไทยค่ะ
อืมนักเรียนออกเสียงยังไงไม่รู้เนแต่ว่า
คนไทยออกเสียงเนี่ยคำว่าสปีด
ค่ะเออนะวันนี้เนี่ยอยากจะชวนครูปุ๊กคุย
เรื่องเกี่ยวกับสีสัน
ออครูชิอยากคุยเรื่องสีเหรอคะใช่ค่ะเพราะ
ว่าถ้าเกิดเราคุยถึงเรื่อง
สีสีที่เราเห็นเนี่ยมันทำให้คนเราเนี่ยมี
ความรู้สึกที่เปลี่ยนไปได้ค่ะครูปุ๊ก
อ๋อครูปุ๊กก็เคยได้ยินมาเหมือนกันครูชินะ
แล้ววันเนี้ยเนี่ยครูชิเนี่ยจะจะเอาแบบสี
ห้องมยหรือว่าสีทาบ้านทาพื้นทาทาอะไรคะ
คือคือเราคุยกันเรื่องของสีเนี่ยเพื่อให้
เรารู้ว่านักเรียนจะได้ฟังภาษาเนอะสีนี้
กับอารมณ์ความรู้สึกอะไรใช่มั้ยทีเนี้ย
เราก็รู้อยู่แล้วว่าเอ่อพอพอมีคนรู้ว่าสี
เนี่ยมันทำให้คนเนี่ยมีความรู้สึกที่
เปลี่ยนไปได้เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยการที่จะออก
แบบห้องออกแบบร้านหรือออกแบบโลโก้ต่างๆ
เนี่ยก็คำนึงถึงสีไงอืคป้ายที่จะโฆษณา
สินค้าก็นึกถึงว่าต้องใช้สีอะไรให้เหมาะ
กับคอเ่าให้เหมาะกับคอนเซปอภาษาไทย
นะแบบภาษาไทยภาษาไทยอะไรอ่ะ
คซคือคนไทยพูดทับศัพท์จนลืมลืมภาษาตัวเอง
มาแล้วมั้งใช่เพราะว่าภาษาไทยมันอาจจะ
ต้องใช้คำออธิบายไงอือใช่มั้ยมันก็เลยจะ
ยาวแต่คำภาษาอังกฤษมันอาจจะคำเดียวสั้นๆ
แต่ความหมายเนี่ยมันครอบคลุมแล้วมันมัน
มันได้ทั้งหมดแล้วอือหือมันตรงกับ
วัตถุประสงค์ใช่มั้ยของการของการที่จะตรง
กับวัตถุประสงค์ของบริษัทตรงกับ
วัตถุประสงค์ของสินค้าตัวนั้นใช่มั้ยก็
เลยออกแบบศีษะมาอืทีเนี้ยต้องให้นักเรียน
รู้จักสีก่อนนะได้เลยค่ะว่าเราเรียกสีว่า
อะไรอ้า
อือย่าง 4 ชุดแรกเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าแม่
สีคะออก็จะอยู่ตรงกลางนะที่เป็นสาม
เหลี่ยมใช่มั้ยคะูชิใช่ค่ะจริงๆก็ก็คือสี
นี้ใช่มั้ยอแล้วก็เอามาให้เห็นตรงกลางให้
ชัดๆอือฮึนะคะแม่สีก็คือสีที่ไม่สามารถ
ผสมให้ได้สีอนั้นได้นะคะเป็นสีที่เกิด
ขึ้นนะคะโดยการที่ไม่มีใครเนี่ยผสมสีออก
มาเป็นแม่สีได้เป็นสีขั้นที่ 1 นะคเราก็
มี 3 สีด้วยกันนะแม่สีค่ะมีสีอะไรบ้างคะ
ครูชิอันนี้ก็มีสีแดงอืนะคะสี
เหลืองและก็สีน้ำเงิน
ค่ะอืทีเนี้ยเราอยากจะได้สีมากขึ้นเราก็
เอาแม่สีเนี่ยมาผสมกันแบบ 50%  50% นะคะ
สีแดงผสมสีเหลืองก็จะได้สีเราเรียกสี
กลุ่มนี้ว่าสีขั้นที่
2 อ๋อขั้นที่ 1 เป็นแม่สีพอเอาแม่สีมา
รวมกันึผสมกันนะก็จะได้สีขั้นที่ 2 นะ่
ขั้นที่ 2
แล้วสีขั้นที่ 2 เนี่ยก็มีความสำคัญเพราะ
ว่าอะไรเพราะว่ามันเป็นสีตรงข้ามกับแม่สี
เห็นมยเป็นสีตรงข้ามกับแม่สีที่มันมี
ประโยชน์ในการที่เราจะเอามาทำเอ่อทำโลโก้
ต่างๆก็มีการผสมสีตรงข้ามกันมาเบรคเอาไว้
นะฮะเราบอกว่าสีที่แบบมาเบรคนะคมาหยุดมา
ลดโลโก้โลโก้ก็เป็นทับศัพท์นะนักเรียนนะ
คำว่าโลโก้ก็คือเครื่องหมายการค้าเนนะของ
ร้านแต่ละร้านเนี่ยมีชื่อร้านอะไรเนี่ยก็
เป็นนะทำออกมาเป็นโลโก้ของเขานะเราก็ใช้
คำง่ายๆเนาะเพราะะนั้นสีขั้นที่ 2 เนี่ย
ก็มีสีส้มค่ะสีส้มก็เกิดจากสีแดงผสมกับสี
เหลืองถูกมยถูกต้องค่ะแล้วก็มีสีเขียวสี
เขียวก็เกิดจากสีน้ำเงินผสมกับสีเหลืองนะ
คแล้วก็สีม่วงค่ะสีม่วงก็เป็นสีที่เกิด
จากสีแดงผสมกับสีน้ำเงินเพราะฉะนั้นสี
ขั้นที่ 2 ก็จะมีสีส้มสีเขียวแล้วก็สี
ม่วงอือหือนะคจริงๆแล้วมันก็ผสมกันได้อีก
นะอย่างสีที่เกิดมานะอย่าง
เงี้ยเกิดจากผสมสีแดงมากกว่าสีเหลืองใช่
มยก็จะเกิดสีมานี้หือหรือสีนี้เกิดจากการ
ผสมสีเหลืองมากกว่าสีแดงมันเยอะเกินไปวัน
นี้เราคุยแค่อยู่ตรงกลางนี้ค่ะเอาแค่แม่
สีและก็สีขั้นที่ 2 พอนะค่ะว่ามันจะ
สามารถสร้างอารมณ์อะไรได้อือฮึนะ
อ้าว
อ่ะแล้วก็ 4 พวกเนี้ยมันจะทำให้เรามีความ
รู้สึกเนาะบางทีเนี่ยเห็นปุ๊บเราก็จะรู้
สึกแบบ
โอ้โหนะแบบอาจจะเกิดความอยากกินอาหารอาจ
จะเกิดจากความรู้สึกแบบโอ้โหทำไมมันเจ็บ
ตาแบบ
นี้แม้แต่เสื้อผ้าที่เราใส่เนาะเราใส่
เสื้อผ้าเนี่ยบางทีเราเราก็ต้องเลือกสี
ให้เหมาะกับตัวเราด้วยนะใส่ออกมาแล้วเรา
จะรู้สึกมั่นใจค่ะนะรู้สึกมีความสุขในการ
ใส่เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยบางคนอาจจะชอบแบบโอโห
ใส่สีแดงเลยนะเวลาคนไทยเห็นโอหือผู้หญิง
คนนี้นะน่าจะเป็นคนแบบเอ่อแรงๆค่ะแรงๆ
หมายถึงว่าเป็นคนที่มั่นใจในตัวเอง
อืทำอะไรแบบอื้อหืออ่ะฟังคนอื่นหรือเปล่า
ไม่รู้แต่มั่นใจว่าตัวเองทำเนี่ยมันถูก
มันดีมันอ่าอ่าดีเลยเพราะฉะนั้นเราพูดถึง
สีแรกนะนสีแดงเนี่ยสีแดงให้ความรู้สึก
อะไรกูปุ๊กความรู้สึกของกูปุ๊กเนี่ยเ้า
บอกว่าแรงใช่มั้ยที่ใช่ร้อนแรงรู้สึกแบบ
โหมันทำให้เรารู้สึกตื่นเต้นหรือว่าอะไร
แบบเนี้ยความรู้สึกมันจะเยอะค่ะนะเห็นม
มันมีความรู้สึกแบบสีแดงเนี่ยมันมีความ
เหมือนกับนักเรียนเข้าใจมยกล้าหาญกล้าหาญ
คือไม่กลัวอะไรเป็นผู้นำนะคเพราะฉะนั้น
ใครที่ตั้งบริษัทมาแล้วบริษัทตัวเองอยาก
จะเป็นผู้นำอยากจะมีความกล้าหาญที่ทำอะไร
ไม่เหมือนคนอื่นนะแล้วมันแบบมีแรงกระตุ้น
มากๆนะหรือถ้าเกี่ยวกับเรื่องของอะไรล่ะ
เอ่ออาหารมันก็จะมีความรู้สึกว่ามันไป
กระตุ้นสมองอ่ะมันกระตุ้นสมองให้มีความ
รู้สึกพอเห็นสีแดงแล้วสมองเรามันจะทำทำ
งานสูบชีมันอยากกินมากขึ้นอืเราเรียกว่า
กระตุ้นนะกระตุ้นก็คือมันทำมันเหมือนไป
ปุกหรือว่าทำให้รู้สึกนะนะก็เป็นสมองเรา
นะเวลาเราตาเราเห็นเนี่ยสมองเราก็รับรู้
แล้วก็คิด
โอโหนะน่ากินหรือว่าอะไรแบบเนี้ยเนาะที่
เวลาเราเห็นอะไรแบบ
โอ้โหสีมันแบบน่ากินน่าอร่อยน่าหรือหรือ
ว่าร้อน
แรงเมื่อเค้ารู้แบบนี้แล้วค่ะครูปุ๊กเค้า
ก็เลยเอาสีแดงเนี่ยมาทำเป็นโลโก้ที่
เกี่ยวกับอาหารก็มีนะหรือมันแสดงถึงความ
รวดเร็วก็ได้นะรวดเร็วอนะอย่าอย่างอย่าง
เช่น netflix เนี่ย netflix เนี่ยมันคง
ไม่ได้หมายถึงแบบการที่แบบร้อนแรงเท่า
ไหร่นะมันอาจจะหมายถึงความเร็วอืนะคะความ
เร็วของอะไร
ของของสิ่งนี้นะคะหรือ CNN เนี่ยเห็นมั้
เป็นอะไรอ่ะแหล่งข่าวที่แบบรวดเร็วไงรวด
เร็ว
นะหรือเราจะเห็นซุปเปอร์ฮีโร่ที่เกี่ยว
กับความเร็ว The  Fast ก็ใช้ The  Flat
ใช่มย The  Flat นะคะก็ใช้สีแดงหรืออ้าว
อย่างงี้อย่างงี้ KFC อย่างเงี้ย KFC
เนี่ยก็แสดงถึง
เอ่อน่าสนใจน่ากินแลอาจแสดงถึงความเร็วก็
ได้นะเป็นอาหารที่รวดเร็ว Fast  Food อ่า
เค้าก็เลยเรียกอาหาร Fast  Food นะก็คือ
ด่วนหรือว่าเร็วค่ะเแล้วก็มีโลโก้นะที่
แสดงถึง
เอ่อสีแดงเยอะแยะไปหมดเลยอาจจะต้องการ
ความเป็นผู้นำต้องการความเร็วอย่าง
YouTube นี่ก็ก็แสดงถึงความความรวดเร็ว
ของเขาคเหมือนกันนะ the  time ที่เป็นเ่ะ
BBC อย่างเงี้ยเห็นมะนะโลโก้ต่างๆเหล่า
เนี้ยก็เกี่ยวข้องกับความเร็วความเป็นผู้
นำต่างๆแล้วมันก็รู้สึกในความโดดเด่นเนอะ
ครูชิโดดเด่นหมายถึงว่าเวลาเรามองป๊าบไป
เนี่ยเหมือนมีคนใส่ชุดเนี่ยหลายๆสีอยู่
แล้วเนาะแต่เราจะไปแบบอุ๊บเราจะไปสะดุดตา
ที่สีแดงมากที่สุดนะเพราะว่ามันเหมือนมัน
ทำให้เราเนี่ยรู้สึกว่าดึงดูดสายตาอืทำ
ให้คนเนี่ยอยากเอาไปเป็นตราสัญลักษณ์หรือ
ว่าโลโก้นะของสินค้าตัวเองอาหารไม่ว่าจะ
เป็นเครื่องดื่มหรืออะไรก็แล้วแต่เนมันทำ
ให้เกิดเเรียกว่ามีพลังค่ะพลังอ่านะเห็นม
พลังมีพลังเยอะค่ะนะ
ต่อไปเรามาคุยถึงสีเหลืองบ้างอ่านีู้ชิมี
สีเหลืองบ้างนิดหน่อยสีเหลืองเนี่ยก็มัน
แสดงถึงความเป็นเพื่อนค่ะแล้วก็มีความสด
ใสร่าเริงอ่าดูแล้วสบายๆเนาะูชิ
อ่ามีความรู้สึกแบบอบอุ่นมีความสุขไงเวลา
เห็นเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยอะไรที่เราอยากจะ
แสดงถึงความรักรักความอบอุ่นนะก็มักจะมา
ในโทนสีเหลืองค่ะนะคะเพราะว่ามองแล้วก็
ไม่เจ็บตาเนาะแล้วก็รู้สึกว่ามันสว่างค่ะ
สว่างอือฮึนี่เห็นมั้ยแสดงถึงเอ่อมีมีสี
เหลืองที่เป็นเพื่อนกับเด็กๆแล้วก็สีแดง
มากระตุ้นให้ความอยากจุ๊บจุ๊บเนี่ยเรา
เรียกจุ๊
ประชุมนะคะหรือเอ่อร้านขายเอ่อเกี่ยวกับ
ไอทีนะร้านบานาน่าอันนี้ก็ใช้โลโก้เป็นสี
เหลืองด้วยแล้วก็แทนบานาน่าด้วยนั่นแหละ
นะคะหรือเชลเออเชลเนี่ยเอ่อใช้สีเหลือง
แล้วก็สีแดงกระตุ้นนะมันเป็นโทนร้อนหมด
เลยนะคะทีเนี้ยมันมันครูปู้ลองนึกถึงดิ
เมืองร้อนเนี่ยเราขับรถมาแบบอากาศร้อนๆ
จริงๆแล้วใช้สีเหลืองกับสีแดงเป็นป้๊ม
น้้ำมันเนี่ยอาจจะคนเข้าน้อยก็ได้นะเพราะ
มันร้อนเหรอคะใช่ครุณปุ๊กคิดดูว่าอากาศ
ร้อนๆเนี่ยพอเห็นป้ายอะไรแดงๆมันรู้สึก
แบบมันสะดุดตาก็จริงนะแต่เห็นมั้ยบาง
อย่างเนี่ยใช้สีแดงให้สะดุดตาเนี่ยดีแต่
เวลาที่เราอยากจะพักพักร้อนน่ะขับรถมา
เหนื่อยๆอยากจะพักร้อนที่ปั๊มน้ำมันน่ะ
ปั๊มน้ำมันสีน้ำเงินเหมือนน้ำใช่มั้ยเลย
มีคนเข้าเยอะไงปตทเลยมีคนเข้าเยอะกว่าเชล
นะอันนี้น้ำสะอาดด้วยมั้ยูชิ
เอมันพอเห็นป้ายสีแดงๆแล้วมันอยากจะผ่าน
มันรู้สึกร้อนแรงอ่ะนะมันอาจจะเป็นทฤษฎี
ของสีทฤษฎีก็คือแบบว่าเขารู้ว่าสีมันมีผล
กับอารมณ์และความรู้สึกยังไงไงใช่มั้ยก็
ก็เลยที่อยากจะต้องบอกเนว่าโอ้โหอันนี้ก็
เหมือนกันนะเห็นมเกอ King ก็เลยเอาหลายสี
มารวมกันค่ะเพราะว่าเอาสีแดงให้ดึงดูด
เหมือนหันไปแล้วเห็นปึ๊บต้องหยุดอ่าเสร็จ
แล้วก็มีสีเหลืองให้มันดูสว่างด้วยแล้วก็
มีสีน้ำเงินมาด้วย
เออหรือหรือของอะไรนะสายการบินนกแอร์ใช่
มั้ยอือฮึสีเหลืองสายการกินต้องแต้องการ
ความเป็นแบบเป็นเพื่อนหรือการ์ตูนอะไรนะ
ที่ที่มันเป็นตัวเหลืองๆอ่ะ
เอ่อนกกับ
ทวิตตี้ใช่มั้ยใช่มั้ยทวิตี้ป่ะที่เป็นนก
มยเป็นเป็นเป็นตัวการ์ตูนที่แบบเป็นตัว
การ์ตูนสีเหลืองอ่ะมันมีมีมีตุ๊กตาแล้วก็
กิบๆพูดเหมือนพูด
บานา
บาเห็นมก็สีเหลืองใช่มกูชิลืมชื่อมันได้
ยัง
ไงผ่านวัยเด็กมานานแล้ว
ค่ะมันเป็นการ์ตูนของเด็กสมัยนี้สมัยูชิ
ยังไม่ยังไม่มีการ์ตูนตัวนี้นะคะหรือ
อันเนี้ยเนี่ยเห็นมั้ยมิสเตอ DIY นะฮ
ต้องการเป็นเพื่อนเพื่อนหนักส่อมต่างๆ
ต้องการเครื่องมือต้องนึกถึงเราอีเกียร์
อย่างเงี้ยโอแม็กรอคะเออสีเหลืองมันก็
เป็นสีเหลืองแดงใช่มั้ยมันก็
เพราะว่าใช้โลโกเป็นโลโก้เป็นตัวอักษรสี
เหลืองก็จริงแต่แต่แผ่นแบกของเขาเป็นสี
แดงนะกระตุ้นให้แบบมีความให้สนใจก่อนใช่
แล้วก็มองสนใจอืนะอเพราะว่าสีเนี่ยมันมัน
ทำให้เรามีความรู้สึกได้ไงนะเาก็เลยต้อง
ใช้สีเนี่ยมาเล่นว่าเอออันนี้ให้สีอะไร
อันนี้สีอะไรสีเดียวบางทีมันทำให้รู้สึก
มันอาจจะกระตุ้นในยการที่เราเห็นได้
เหมือนสีแดงอย่างเดียวเนาะแบบมันก็แบบเออ
สะดุดตาแต่มันก็ไม่ได้ดึงดูดสายตาเราเข้า
ไปอีกเราอาจจะดูแล้วโอเคนะแต่ถ้าสีมันผสม
กันเนี่ยมันอาจจะทำให้เรารู้สึกแบบโอ้โห
นะทำให้มันดูสวยขึ้นก็ได้นะดูเด่นขึ้น
หรือมันช่วยทำให้สีใช่มั้ยสีพื้นก็คือสี
แบ็คกราวด์ข้างหลังหรือว่าเป็นภาพหรือว่า
อันเนี้ยนะแล้วก็มีสีแดงอยู่ตรงกลางหรือ
อะไรแบบเนี้ยมันก็ทำให้สีแดงเนี่ยมันเด่น
ขึ้นมาอีกเพิ่มพลังให้สีแดงเข้าไปอีกอืนะ
อือหือก็อันนี้ก็เป็นวิธีคิดของเา้าเนาะ
ใช้อารมณ์ของสีเนี่ยมาผสมออ่ะใช่ทีนี้ลอง
มาดูสีน้ำเงินบ้าง
อืมสีน้ำเงินไสีน้ำเงินถ้าเราดูนะเอ่อ
เปรียบเทียบแล้วเนี่ยสีน้ำเงินก็แสดงถึง
แบบความสดใสะเอ้ยไม่ใช่เอ่อความแข็งแกร่ง
ความเชื่อมั่น
อแข็งแกร่งหมายถึงแบบเรานึกถึงแบบสีของ
ท้องฟ้าสีของน้ำใช่มยมันเหมือนกับเป็นที่
พึ่งได้นะคทำให้เรามีความเชื่อมั่นนะคบาง
คนบอกสีน้ำเงินหมายถึงแรงศรัทธาเพราะ
ฉะนั้นแบบเห็นมั้ยธงชาติไทยเนี่ยก็จะมีสี
แดงที่หมายถึงเลือดพลังการเป็นผู้นำสี
น้ำเงินหมายถึงความซื่อสัตย์เป็นตัวแทน
ของของพระมหากษัตริย์ไทยนะนะก็หลายๆ
ประเทศเนาะก็ใช้สีน้ำเงินนะเป็นเกี่ยวกับ
ในหลวงเกี่ยวกับพระมหากษัตริย์นะอือก็
เป็นสีน้ำเงิน
ค่ะก็มีหลายบริษัทนะที่ใช้โลโก้ที่เป็นสี
น้ำเงินดูแล้วมันเย็นๆตายนะอือฮึใช่ค่ะ
มองก็เป็นมิตรเป็น
เพื่อนดูแล้วสบายตาค่ะไม่เจ็บ
ตาอ่าแต่เห็นมเค้าก็บางบางบางโลโก้เค้าก็
จะผสมนะตราสัญลักษณ์บางที่เค้าก็จะผสมสี
เพื่อเอาสีแดงมาดึงดูดสายตาก่อนแล้วก็
ค่อยเอาสีอื่นเนี่ยมาทำให้มันดูเบาลงเห็น
มั้ยถ้าครูปุ๊กขับรถมาร้อนๆเนี่ยอยากจะ
เข้าปั๊มเชลหรือปตทคะหรือ PTT คะ PTT
ค่ะเพราะว่าขับมาก็นะข้างนอกมันก็แสงแดด
ร้อนๆแล้วก็เรารู้สึกว่าการไปเติมน้ำมัน
มันก็ร้อนๆนะเกี่ยวกับเครื่องยนต์เกี่ยว
กับพลังอะไรอย่างเงี้ยนะก็พอไปเจอสี
น้ำเงินมันก็ทำให้สบายตาขึ้นค่ะทำให้เย็น
ด้วยแล้วปั๊มปรทนะมีแต่สีน้ำเงินสีฟ้าสี
น้ำเงินสีฟ้าเข้าไปแล้วมันรู้สึกอบอุ่นนะ
ไม่ไม่รู้สึกว่ามันมันมันร้อนไม่เป็น
เพื่อนนะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นความรู้สึกของของ
เรานะหรือแม้แต่เครื่องดื่มอ่ะเครื่อง
ดื่มบางอย่างอย่างอย่างโคคาโคลาเนี่ยเใช้
สีแดงใช่มยเพื่อกระตุ้นให้ความอยากกินแต่
คู่แข่งเนี่ยกับใช้สีน้ำเงินไงอือเซี่
เนี่ยเพราะอะไรสีน้ำเงินมันไม่ได้กระตุ้น
ถึงความอยากมากแต่มันทำให้เรารู้สึกก้า
หายเหมือนกันแต่มันรู้สึกว่าเวลาเราเรา
เหมือนกับมันเป็นเกี่ยวกับน้ำเนาะนะ่เรา
ก็จะรู้สึกถึงความสดชื่นความเย็นนะอือนะ
กับสีนะคะใช่หรือแม้นแต่เนี่ย Twitter
Facebook ก็ใช้ใช้โลโก้ที่เป็นโทนสีฟ้า
แสดงถึงความเป็นเพื่อน
นะเป็นเพื่อนไว้วางใจ
ได้ร์เเปลี่ยนเป็น x ล
ค่ะโอ้อะไรคะนะคะหรือือูชิเห็นมีหลายๆ
โลโก้นะที่เราเราใช้เป็นโทนสีสีน้ำเงิน
น่ะเยอะแยะไปหมดเลยซึ่งแสดงถึงความเป็น
มิตรนะฮเห็นมย
Samsung
BMW นะแม้นแต่เรื่องของเอ่อเทคโนโลยี
ต่างๆเนนะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นโลโก้นะ Nokia
ด้วยเห็นมยใช่อ่าแสดงถึงความเป็นความเป็น
เพื่อนเป็นมิตรด้วยกัน
อ่าคือด้วยความที่มันเป็นความร้อนไง
เกี่ยวกับความร้อนอย่างเครื่องยนต์หรือ
ว่าคอมพิวเตอร์เนมันก็รู้สึกว่ามันใช้
ความร้อนเยอะนะแต่ถ้าใช้สีแดงร้อนกับร้อน
น่ะมันเหมือนความรู้สึกคนใช้มันจะยิ่ง
ร้อนเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยของใช้ที่ร้อนๆเ้าก็
อาจจะลดลดความลดความรู้สึกร้อนเนี่ยโดย
การใช้สีน้ำเงินก็ไดู้ชิอือหือหรือสีฟ้า
ค่ะทีนี้เรามาดูโทนสีที่เป็นสีขั้นที่ 2
นะคะก็คือคือสีส้มใช่มั้ยใช่สีส้มเนี่ยก็
แสดงออกถึงความมั่นใจนะกระตือรือล้นเป็น
กันเองอ่ะมันเหมือนกับรวมๆคือจะไม่แดงจน
เกินไปมันลดความแดงลงมานะนะกระตือรือล้น
ก็คือเหมือนกับว่าเป็นคนที่อยากแบบมีพลัง
อ่ะอยากทำอยากนะคนที่มีความเหมือนไปทำงาน
อย่างเงี้ยอุ้ยวันนี้เราอยากจะทำงานจะแบบ
อื้อหือมีความแบบอยากจะทำแบบเหมือนพยายาม
ที่จะหาอะไรมาทำเยอะๆนะมันรู้สึกแบบตื่น
เต้นกับการที่เราจะทำอะไรอย่างเงี้ยมันทำ
ให้รู้สึกมีพลังอ่ะไม่อยู่นิ่งอืนะคะแต่
มันไม่ได้ร้อนแรงจนถึงสีแดงใช่มยใช่มันก็
มีหลายๆบริษัทนะหลายๆโลโก้ที่ใช้โทนสีส้ม
มาในการทำนะมาแม้แต่เนี่ย
ช้อปี้นะคะแฟนต้าอันนี้แฟนต้าน้ำส้มนะมัน
ดีไม่พ้นมันต้องใช้สีส้มนะคะหรือหรือหรือ
ฟอกใช่มยใช่หรือ
ธนาคารที่แสดงถึงแบบความกระตือรือล้นนะคะ
อันนี้ธนาคารนี้กระตือรือล้นจริงมั้ย
คะพอดีมันโดนดับด้วยนะเนี่ยโดนลดความร้อน
โดยกกระตือรูล้นโดยการใช้สีอะไรสีดำมาผสม
แต่สีดำมันแสดงถึงความมั่นคงเนี่ยเอ่า
มั่นคงกับมั่นใจเอามารวมกันนะฮเพื่อ
กระตุ้นให้รู้ว่าจงเชื่อใจฉันจงมั่นใจฉัน
นะมาตรการนะเอาทั้งแดงทั้งส้มเลยค่ะนะ
คอย่านี้อามาซอนเอออมาซอนนี่ตัวอักษรสีดำ
นะแต่ยังอุตส่าห์ใช้เส้นสีส้มเพื่อมาให้
ให้เป็นลูกสอที่แบบหมายถึงว่ามันรวดเร็ว
เหมือนกันนะอืนะก็สีดำมันก็เด่นเนาะ
เหมือนคล้ายๆสีแดงแต่ว่ามันไม่ร้อนแรง
เท่ากับสีแดงไง
นะแล้วก็อันนี้ก็เป็นเรื่องของสีส้มถัด
จากสีส้มนะเราก็มีสีอะไรล่ะสีแดงเมื่อกี้
สีแดงผสมสีเหลืองเป็นสีส้มสีแดงผสมสี
น้ำเงินอืก็สีม่วงสีแดงผสมสีน้ำเงินก็มา
เป็นสีม่วงอ้านี่นะสีม่วง
ออก็มีหลายๆอย่างนะที่ใช้สีม่วงอื้อหือ
อื้อหือแล้วบอกสีม่วงเนี่ยแสดงถึงเอ่อ
อะไรล่ะเป็นเป็นเป็นสีที่มันเหมือนกับว่า
เป็น
เอ่อคือความแตกต่างอ่ะมีความแตกต่างจาก
ที่อื่นต้องการเป็นเอ่อเป็นที่
1 โดด
เด่นต้องต้องการความโดดเด่นและความแตก
ต่างจากคนอื่นนะก็พยายามใช้สีมม่วงที่มา
บ่งบอกนะรวมทั้งมันก็เลยมีเรื่องของการ
บินไทยนะการบินไทยเราใช้สีม่วงอืออ่าใช่
เพราะว่าเค้าจะมีดอกกล้วยไม้ค่ะดอกกล้วย
ไม้ใช่มั้ยเออที่ติดนะเป็นดอกไม้ชนิดนึง
นะชื่อว่ากล้วยไม้ดอกกล้วยไม้เป็นสีม่วง
นแล้วก็มาเป็นโลโก้ BBC มีโลโก้ที่เป็นสี
ม่วงด้วยเหรอไม่ใช่สไม่ใช่สีแดงที่เป็น
แบบความเร็วข่าวนะคะเห็นมคะโอจริงๆมี
โลโก้เยอะนะที่ใช้สีม่วงใช่มยเป็น
เอะอันนี้ก็แสดงถึงความคือต้องการเป็นผู้
นำแล้วต้องการความแตกต่างมาเป็นอันดับ
1 ต้องการความแตกต่างหลากหลายมั้ยความ
หลากหลายมีเพราะว่ามันเหมือนเอาสีแดงกับ
สีน้ำเงินน่ะซึ่งมีความแตกต่างกันอย่าง
มากใช่มั้ยมันแบบเรื่องความร้อนกับน้ำ
อย่างเงี้ยอพอเอามาผสมกันแล้วมันให้ความ
แตกต่างมั้ยเอยากให้สื่อถึงอย่างงั้นมั้ย
อืคือถ้าสีน้ำเงินเนี่ยมันดูมันมันยังไม่
มีความแรงเกินไปไงมันมีความเป็นมิตรเป็น
เพื่อนเยอะแต่ถ้าเราเป็นสีม่วงเนี่ยมัน
เหมือนกับต้องการที่จะเป็นเอ่อเพิ่มความ
เป็นสีแดงเข้าไปในสีน้ำเงินมันเหมือนกับ
ต้องการแสดงความเป็นผู้นำในส่วนนั้นเข้า
มาด้วยอืไม่ให้อ่อนจนเกินไปใช่มั้ยใช่ก็
เอาพลังมาใส่ด้วยอืคือแล้วแล้วสีม่วงมัน
แสดงถึงความ
หรูหรารู้ราคือแบบโอ้โหเหมือน
เอ่อเหมือนโรงแรมใช่มั้ยถ้าโรงแรมหรู
เนี่ยก็จะเป็น 5 ดาวค่ะไสตนะ 5 ดาวนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยแพง
ค่ะพวกที่หรูราเนี่ยจะมาด้วยความแพงค่ะนะ
อย่างรถยนต์ก็ไม่ใช่รถธรรมดาต้องเป็นรถ
สปอร์ตอย่าเงี้ยหรูหรา
นะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นเรื่องของสีม่วงอืต่อมา
สีเขียวค่ะสีเขียวเนี่ยก็เป็นเรื่อง
เกี่ยวกับธรรมชาตินะเรื่องของชีวิตสุขภาพ
อะไรที่มันบ่งอ่าึงความเป็นมิตรเป็น
เพื่อนกับธรรมชาติอืเพราะว่าเวลาเรามองสี
เขียวอ่ะเราจะรู้สึกสบายตาเหมือนได้พัก
ผ่อนนะเคให้มองสีเขียวนะนักเรียนเวลาเรา
ทำงานเครียดเราใช้สายตาเยอะพักสายตาด้วย
การมองอะไรที่เป็นสีเขียวๆโดยเฉพาะใบไม้
นะหรือว่าต้นข้าวที่กำลังโตอย่างเงี้ย
เป็นสีเขียวทั้งหมดอ่ะแล้วเวลาลมพัดเนี่ย
มันพริ้วไหวนะมันก็จะทำให้อารมณ์เนี่ยเรา
เนี่ยรู้สึกสบายมากขึ้นรู้สึก
เ้อผ่อนคลายค่ะทำให้ความเครียดเราหายไปนะ
ทำให้เรารู้สึกสบายใจมากขึ้นนะมีความสุข
มากขึ้น
นะสีเขียวเนี่ยนอกจากคิดถึงต้นไม้ใบหญ้า
แล้วก็คิดถึง
ไร่ไไ
ไร
อ่า starbuck ด้วยนักเรียนอาจจะคิดถึง
ช้างหรือบางคนชอบ
Starbucks ใช่นะแต่เราก็จะคิดถึง
รเพราะว่าคนไทยใช้ไงนะนักเรียนอาจจะใช้
แอปพลิเคชันอื่นเนาะแต่ว่าคนไทยเนี่ยใช้ล
อ่าแต่เราเนี่ยไรยอ่านักเรียนมาประเทศไทย
ก็อาจจะสนใจกับเบียร์ช้างค่ะอ่าใช่มยอัน
นี้เนี่ยก็เป็นเรื่องของสีเขียวค่ะนะคะ
นอกจากเอ่อสีเขียวแล้วก็จะมีสีอะไรนะสีดำ
อ่าโลโก้ที่เป็นสีดำเนี่ยก็สีดำก็จะแสดง
ถึงแบบ
เอ่อแบบความเข้มแข็งมัคงความแปล้งอย่าง
งี้
มยมันมันคือต้องต้องรู้จักใช้สีดำด้วยนะ
ถ้าใช้สีดำที่มีในชิ้นใหญ่ๆมันอาจจะรู้
สึกหดหู่ไงมันดูเงียบเหงาดำๆแต่พอไปใช้สี
ดำที่เออเป็นโทนที่ไปผสมผสมเนี่ยมันทำให้
ดูหรูดูน่าติดตามูแทงเหรอเออเ้าคูปุ๊นึก
ถึงเวลาที่เราไปร้านกาแฟแล้วร้านกาแฟไหน
แต่งเป็นสีดำมันรู้สึกแบบมันดูแบบดู
หรูน่าสงสัยน่าติดตามันมันมีความรู้สึก
ว่ามีความลับลมคม
ในโอ๊ยแต่วันนี้เนี่ยูชิคะมันหมดเวลาแล้ว
อ้ายังโอเคอย่างน้อยเราก็ได้สีแม่สีกับสี
แล้วลำดับดับนี้ครูชิกะจะเอาดำขาวซะอีก
หน่อยแล้วก็หลๆสีไม่เป็นไรเอา
ไว้เอาไว้ค่อยคุย
กันนะวันนี้ก็คุยกันได้นะหมดเวลาแล้วทำ
ให้เราเนี่ยต้องไปก่อนนะอืขอบคุณูชินะคะ
ขอบคุณค่ะขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายค่ะ